we get to see the earliest iteration of
the Stormtrooper in Clone Troopers these
clones were created to serve as the army
of the galactic Republic and were
genetically engineered to be obedient
soldiers loyal to the Jedi Order the
phase one colorful armor was later
replaced with the more iconic black and
white armor this Phase 2 Armor was
adopted by nearly all cloned soldiers of
the galactic Republic by the final days
of the Clone Wars TK Troopers
represented the rise of human recruits
instead of relying on cloning they were
trained by clone commandos as part of
project War mantle and were a prototype
armor which was based on the phase 2
clone trooper armor the Empire finally
developed a stormtrooper armor as is
most popular today this armor featured
improved ventilation and mobility and it
provided additional protection for the
wearer following the fall of the
Galactic Empire a number of Imperial
loyalists formed the Imperial Remnant a
group that sought to restore the empire
to power many Stormtroopers remained
loyal to the Empire and joined this
Remnant the first order Stormtroopers
were trained from birth and taken from
their families to instill loyalty in the
first order